I think because of just the complexity
of environmental problems today,
I think that there's going to be
a big role and a kind of profession
around process design,
so not technical or technological process design
because those jobs exist now,
but more social process design.
And I think there will be jobs available
for people who really understand
both, like, the complexity of the environment
and social and political issues
but also are able to design very effective processes
to get us from one stage to another.
I think there's a lot of people
who know what they want the world to look like
and there are people who know what we should do,
but the path between aspiration and action
is still a little bit blurry,
so I think there's going to be jobs
for people who make that much clearer.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.